Are you happy with your choice?
- I think it looks fun!
It's not my choice, hey...
Let's be clear about that.
It's like a children house.
- You guysare building a circus?
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update.
In previousupdates, you saw us turning
this pig trailer into a house.
We put up the walls the floor, and italso has a roof now.
In this update, we're going to fill in the walls with
this recycled textileand cover the walls with this panels.
We made a design and we asked the people to vote forit.
And, the vote has been made!
So, today, we're going to build whatever vote won.
It's kind of scary.
Plus, this week, we had some challenges
with our upgraded electricity net.
And, wesolved another common problem,
which you might have as well!
So, stay with us until the end.
- We received a call that they dropped off the insulation for the trailer.
We're going tobring it down
and leave it inside of the pig trailer.
- One...
Okay, we are going to work
in the inside of the pig trailer first.
We are going to insulate it withrecycled textile,
and we've put a vapor barrier on.
- We are still waiting on the materials forthe roof.
Because, it's raining a lot...
There's water everywhere.
So, we have some leaks, andit's not really good for the roof...
Meanwhile, we're going to start putting the electric boxes in,
where the switches and the plugs are going.
So, this is the socket that theplug goes in to.
What Jaime is doing now is that he's putting them
on the walls, where they'resupposed to go.
But now, nothing can hold them,
so he screws them in the panels.
Once theinsulation is going to be around it, carrying it...
We can then take the nails out.
After that, we press in the holes and this is
where the cables are going through.
So, the whole systemis going to be designed
between the two layers of insulation.
We're going to show you that.
- We have the boxes in place right there.
And, right now, Colleen just marked all the points,
where I have to drill holes to run all the cables.
- All right, so, we made all the holesfor the electric cables,
and now we're going to put the first layer of insulation.
So,it's going to be: first layer, cable, second layer.
But, today, we can only do thefirst one.
This is a kind of a fabric, textile, compressed insulation.
That's what we're going to use.
Let's go!
- Let's go!
The video making team also working.
So, right now we can start pulling thecables
through all the switches, socketsand everything.
We're using this cable.
Ithas a metal and rubber cover.
So, yeah, we're only using the cable.
I know weshould use electric pipes,
but it's a lot of plastic that we don't want to use...
We'regoing to start running cables through the whole trailer.
I don't know where the medium is.
- This is where the fuse box is going to be.
It's right next to the door.
So, all the cables are going to be connected to this.
We have two rooms.
So, wedivided where the cables are going through.
A cable run through which is always at 50 cm,
just so we then don't drillin it during the weaving.
Then, you have the split boxes, because you don't want
all the cables tobe connected to the fuse box.
Because it's too many cables, you use use split boxes.
So, you putthem strategically where you want to spread out,
and then the cables are used in a more efficient way.
You havealso these very simple cables,
that connect to the sockets.
Then, you have a plug andit's so crazy, it's magical!
That's how it's done.
- So, we ran all the wires and now we're going
to start connecting all the cables in the split boxes.
We're using these connectors.
We havea knife.
So, connecting them is pretty simple.
We have these Wago connections.
We just open up theclips.
And, we put all the colors together.
Oops -- the other way around...
We close the clip.
And then, wedo the same with all the colors.
All the cables are in!
So, now, the last part is to put
onthe second layer of insulation.
Then, we are going to put down the tarp
and seal it on thefloor.
Insulation and the tarp: that's the mission for today!
As you can see, we're creating a bighot box!
We're putting this black tarp, that is called anti vapor?
- A vapor barrier.
A vaporbarrier, which that means that the vapor
cannot go into the insulation, which is good!
Here, wenow applied it around the window.
They're sealing it with some tape
around the edges, so it's nice and sharp.
- We finished the vapor barrier.
Well, reallythe biggest part of the interior.
You can show everybody!
- Woohoo!
Everything is sealed.
So, as youcan see, the walls are meeting the roof here.
But, there is a little gap left by the beams.
So, inorder to have our house completely insulated...
We need to fill these gaps.
So, we're going to makelittle bags,
that look a bit like this.
We're just going to stuff them inside there.
we cut a piece of leftover tarp from our insulation
Some leftover insulation shredded.
Thenwe're going to place them and make a little roll
There you have it!
Yourhomemade insulated cushion!
- After insulating the whole box, the pig traileris
starting to look and feel more like a house.
The temperature inside is now stable.
The wallsare ready to receive the final layer.
Now, it's time to work on the outside.
Wait a second!
Wewant to introduce our sponsor for this video.
That's Milanote.
Okay, so, what's Milanote?
It'sa tool to work on creative projects.
In our case, building a house from a pig trailer
might be a bitmore technical...
But, you could also say it serves
to organize projects in a creative way.
So, this fitsquite well with the variety of
skills we have in Project Kamp.
Because, you have a lot of templates tostart with,
depending on your profession.
Or, the projects you're doing.
You can tailor it to your needsblending many inputs,
like test images, videos, color switches, whatever!
Then, you put it on boards or you can organize it with columns.
Definitely very easy and flexible!
This flexibility allowsdifferent approaches to work with it.
For example, we asked Ingrid for some inspiration inputs,
and sheloves moodboards!
So, she made a moodboard.
Here we have it!
Or, wait, I'm going to drop a commenthere.
Okay, let's see another way on how we can use it!
Let's say Dave wants to discuss where to place the pigtrailer.
So, he creates a board, drops a map there,
and we can discuss on it
Or, maybe, you prefer it ina more traditional way.
You can leave a bunch of to-do lists and links,
but they will look muchbetter than if you do it in another place.
You can even watch the videos!
Or, you can just drop a filethere,
and then somebody else can grab it!
It's very versatile!
Another cool thing is the Web Clipper.
Let's say: you want to build a shed for the pig trailer.
So, you go online for some inspiration and using the Web Clipper,
you can get any picture, link or video.
And, boom!
You already have it in Milanote!
Then, you can invite other people
to edit this board or the whole thing.
If you wantexternal feedback, you can also send a read-only link.
You can customize it by allowing commentsdownloads setting up a welcome message or even a password for security
In the end, there are manyways to collaborate just by sharing a link!
So, Milanote is a cool tool!
It's availablefor free and without a time limit!
You can check it out in the link in the description
to start on organizing your projects in a different way!
So, that was our sponsor for this video!
Now, we are getting closer to get a tractor or a digger.
We're still deciding!
You can find more in ourresearch topic.
As we said ,we would get one of them with four advertisements.
We have made threeso far.
So, there's only one to go!
And now, we're going to jump into the pig trailer again.
Inprevious updates, we found some HPL panels at the scrapyard.
So, this will probably be theshell of our pig trailer.
We have different sizes, in different colors.
As you can see, they arequite bright colors.
Blue, green, pink and orange.
But, we couldn't decide on
the colors and how tocombine them...
So, we thought it would be a cool idea to get some help!
We proposed a bunch of differentlayouts
for our Patreons to vote on.
They did it!
Here we are, back in the scrapyard.
Afterthe voting on Patreon, they choose 25% of each color!
So we will get all this HPL, high-pressurelaminate,
with some phenolic layer.
It's good to be outside and to protect from the weather.
It'sactually coming from all the stands,
from this guy that collected it here.
So, thanks to Patreon,we will have a very characteristic trailer!
It's a bit heavy.
- A bit?!
Let's take another look at the pickup
when we arrive at Project Kamp.
How are the tires?
- Not good, we have to pump themup.
A little challenge here!
We'll make it.
- Okay, so, we have the material here.
The high-pressure laminates.
And, right now, we have to prep it.
So, we have to cut it to size, drill holes...
Then, we'll fit it in.
First, we have to clean everything,
because it's disgusting rightnow...
And, yeah, Colleen and I came up with
a really cool system, but we already started it.
We thought all the spaces were even the same size, but...
When we went to fit the first piecein, it wasn't.
So, we made a incredible list of all the colors,
and all the differentsizes and cuts.
Right now, we're going to clean all the pieces.
Then, cut all the pieces tosize, and then put them in.
So, yeah, let's start.
- After measuring and cleaning the HPL, it's time to cut!
Now, we are drillingthe holes.
For that, we made a mold.
Finally, it's time to start paneling!
Let's see what this goingto look like!
- No, it's okay, it's okay!
I think it'sbroken...
- We now pre-drill them, because we don't want to break the bottom.
We wanted to experiment with those screws
that contain stainless steel.
They arefor outside, and they don't rust.
So, one side is going to be with stainless steel screws.
And, theother side is going to be with normal screws.
Just so we can see what happens.
- Dave and Rita were some days off.
This is theirfirst reaction!
- Are you trying to get a reaction?
Yes!
- What do you think?
It's half cleaned.
- There's a camera recording!
I didn't see it!
- Are you happy with your choice?
I think looksfun!
- It's not my choice, hey...
Let's be clear about that!
- It's a recycled village!
It's like a children house...
- I would have gone for blue or green only.
I voted for it!
- You guys are building a circus here!
It looks likeit!
Okay, we finished two sides!
Two more to go!
The two more to go are a bit more tricky, but the energy is there.
- It's there!
Let's go!
Why is it tricky?
It's just a matter of sliding things through really.
- Throughwhere?
So, as you can see, there's like a metal beam here
with the our overhang that protects usfrom the sun.
And, we like the shade, so we want to keep it.
So, we need to --
- What do weneed to do?
Put the planks in.
- How does it go?
When a video maker joins the workspace.
A natural builder!
- Huh?
- The paneling is done!
So, now, we can properlysee how this turn out.
I would say quite unique!
It's probably the only in the world that lookslike this.
It used to look like this.
This is what Patreon voted for.
And now, it looks likethis!
An interesting choice!
The goal was to reuse materials,
but we only had four bright colors tochoose from.
Let's see if the people like it!
- I'm fine with it.
No.
- They're very interesting.
Yeah, theymake me happy!
- Yes!
Cool! Let us know what you think!
- Okay Patreons, so, this is it.
We hope youdon't regret the beautiful art piece we got over here.
And next, we're going to make theroof waterproof.
This time, really waterproof, but first we need to do another upgrade.
With somecloudy and rainy days coming,
we are running out of electricity...
This means that we cannot use manypower tools.
We need to improve this situation, so we can work
with many people and cloudy daysagain.
- In Project Kamp, we live mainly off-grid.
These six solar panels are holding us since Season 1.
Sofar, it has been working kind of good.
Sometimes, we are a bit tight depending on the weather,
andthe amount of people in the Kamp.
But, in this Season, since we increase
the amount of projects andpeople living here...
It became just not enough, even in sunny days and especially in cloudy days.
We already mentioned this in previous challenge-videos.
And, after some checking and research,
we decidedto double our number of panels.
Just to increase our solar production especially on cloudy days.
Wedon't think we need to increase
our battery capacity for the moment.
We just need to chargethem faster,
when there's not much sunlight.
As a temporary solution, we decided to install it
on topof our recycled plastic roof.
We know it's not the best angle.
We know it's not the best structure tohold it.
But, in the meantime, while we think about a proper solution...
We already need to use them.
Wewill go with this.
The first step is to put the frame on our roof,
and on top, the solar panels.
For that,we have the help of Colline and Julien.
And, later on, we will install all the connections
to hook itto our current system.
But first: meet Colline!
- Hello! I'm Colline!
I'm from France and I came last season
tohelp with the repairing of the sketch ruin.
Now, I'm back to keep learning about construction.
I want tolearn how to do everything in order to live.
Starting with a house!
You could say that I'm preparingmyself to
leave the system one brick at a time.
Getting knowledge about making and repairing,
and making that knowledge accessible...
It's what I plan to do all my life.
No better place thanhere to do so.
On the long run, I would like to get deeper into natural building.
I really lovemud!
It's like I was born in a swamp, much like Shrek,
whom I identify as strongly.
We'regoing to do the solar panel on the roof today.
But, our roof is a bit too small,
so we want toextend it.
We have some wood here from last year
that we used for the roof.
But, finally in the end,we chose to exchange it from a thinner thing.
Anyway, we have some leftover!
So, we're goingto use this, and it's red cedar.
It goes well for a long run in the rain!
We're going to use this, and let's go!
Follow me.
- Since it is a temporary setup,
wedon't want to screw them on theplastic sheets.
Or, damage the actualstructure
So, we are going to add some pieces of wood
to the actualsetup, where we can screw them to the frame.
- Cool!
For the frame, that keeps the panelstogether...
We will use an aluminium profile, in order to avoid
as much weight aswe can on top of our roof.
For the old setup, we have made a metal frame.
But, thiswould be too heavy for our recycled plastic room!
These are the solar panels we aregoing to install.
They are slightly bigger than the ones we had before.
Before, we had 470 Watt panels.
Now, we are going for slightly bigger, 550 Watt panels!
They are also slightly bigger but still willfit on our roof.
We are a bit afraid that the roof can collapse
with the solar panelsand with us on top...
So, we're going to use this!
Safety first!
Now, we are going to place one Female down, one Male up...
We are going to secure it with duct tape.
So then, when we put up the cables,
they are in the right place already.
Otherwise, it could be difficult to find the cable and connect them...
Because, we cannot really work underneath the panel.
They're all aligned and hopefully,
we also solve theleaks with this solution!
- So, the first one is here!
Nice!
We're going for the last two!
We're killing it!
- What's the problem?
It doesn't fit.
You need to move again a bit.
2 millimeters!
So, the solar panels are alreadyup.
They are still not harvesting energy...
The next step would be to connect it toour current system.
- Let's go!
Let's do it!
Okay, so, the solar panels are already in place,
andnow it's time to hook them to our actual system.
Our current system was set up by Dave in Season 1.
In order to increase our solar production capacity,
we also need to add some new elements.
And, forthis, we would need to add
a new board on top to keep it tidy and nice.
Let me show you what wehave now.
So, here we have our our new components.
We have a new solar regulator!
A new fuse boxfor solar panels with the fuses inside!
We have another fuse here.
We have all the cablesto make all
the connections and put everything together.
So, I also made a simple diagram thatintegrates the old system,
the new system and all the wiring needed.
What I'm going to dois to mount
as much as I can in the new board in the workspace.
In order to facilitate theconnections there later
and the working of it in the back of the wall.
So, as much is going to happen here.
And, the rest will happen in the electricity box.
Now, what I'm going to do is to pickthe cables
of the solar panels we already connect.
To bring them to our solar box.
Weasked the shop to already crimp our solar cables.
Because, they have a specificconnection and
we don't have the tools to do it here.
Now, we already have it!
Wejust need to plug the cables into the panels.
So, now, we made already the holes.
We're going to bring the cable from
up here to inside our box.
I'm goingto cover these ventilation holes
with the cardboard, in order to protect itfrom the dust.
Just so the dust doesn't go in the batteries.
Now, we are going to mount a new fuse.
It's an 80 Ampere fuse that will protect our solarpositive,
before it goes into the system.
The last piece is going in!
I also have some help from someonewith long arms.
We have a volunteer here.
Hey Dave!
- Hey!
So, now, I'm going to turn everything off.
First solar, then the inverter and the batteries.
We're going to disconnect the battery,
and then disconnectsome cables we have.
We needto make bigger holes here too.
That's sketchy.
So, we havedisconnected all the electricity of the Kamp.
Everyone is having dinnerwith not much light...
So now, I'm going to reconnect everything again.
Then, wehave electricity and we can continue our lives.
This time, we turn on everything to see if it works.
So, we already finished to connecteverything!
We have the solar panels in place!
The wiring here!
It all seems that it's working properly.
Today, it's not a super sunny day, but we finally can use our kettle,
our washing machine and whatever wewant.
It's technically how it can be 'sunny' here.
The solar panels are in place!
They work very good.
Wehave way more electricity every day.
We don't have limitations anymore.
Even in cloudy days, we canuse as much electricity as we want!
Ready for more people, ready for more projects and ready forwinter.
In the end, we also cleaned the solar panels from the dirt.
And, we noticed that our towels aretearing apart...
- Hi Julie! What are doing here?
Hey! I'm actually drying the cutlery, but yeah...
Thistowel is a bit broken, I would say.
This happens often!
We have many broken towels.
So, what can wedo to fix the towel?
Do we throw it away, or try to fix it?
Preferably fixing it, but personally,
I wouldn't know how to do it...
- Oh! Then, we can try!
That would be great!
- We have some pretty brokenkitchen towels here.
And, we have the sewing machine!
So, we're now trying to repair those.
This one is quite damaged, so we will use this as
the batches to repair those towels.
And, we'll startwith this one.
We'll cut this fabric into a little square...
Then, we'll try to sew this patch onto this.
This one is the first two patches I'vedone it with.
And, I was not very happy about it, as you can see.
It is still quite raw here, and you can still see the edges
here that is easily to be peeled off.
So, I thought of anothermethod that
I locked into the sewing machine.
I see that the there are different stitcheshere.
So, I change it into the zigzag stitch,
so the edges can be uh securely locked here.
Also, I do an other stitch around the holes here.
And, hopefully, the kitchen towels canlast longer!
I will cut a small square like this.
Okay, so, we got a patch here.
And then, we'll then sew it onto the hole.
Then, we will turn it to another side...
And then, we'lluse the zigzag stitch to lock the little holes here.
Okay, so, I'm now finished with one patch.
More patches to go!
So, this is how I tryto repair
the kitchen towels with the sewing machine!
But, if you have any other ideas to do it at home,
or how can we do this without using a machine...
Feel free to share it with us!
- So, wegot a colorful pig trailer very close to being a home
Or, a disco...
We don't know what we're aregoing for yet.
We also have the solar panels already installed on the roof.
So, we can achieveall the cloudy days with some electricity!
And, the towels got fixed!
A quite a lot of things being completed!
Next week, we will will be preparing ourselves
for the rain that is coming.
Because, we are close towinter time...
We will also be working on a lake
that we were trying to make.
Not sure how thatis going to go, but let's see!
So, if you want to see that episode one week ahead,
you can supportus on Patreon.
See this episode even without ads!
And, if not, we see you here on YouTube.
Same channel, same time!
All right! Have a nice week!